hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in his essay bartleby or the formula
jill duluz
invokes a very interesting formula of
his own or we could say
phrase and expression melvilian
psychiatry and this comes about halfway
through
the essay he says we're in the process
of melding together's characters
as different as ahab the captain
searching for moby dick in that novel
and he says yet does not everything set
them in opposition to each other
malvillian psychiatry constantly invokes
two poles and we're going to get to
looking at that in just a moment he
calls these monomaniacs and
hypochondriacs and these are
you know this is coming from a book
called essays critical
and clinical and these are clinical
terms developed within
psychiatry but it's kind of a funny
thing to say
isn't it because there isn't psychiatry
as such
in the time of melville
the psychoanalytic terms that the lose
himself is going to bring in
that's a later theory so is he
reading backwards as so many people are
prone to do as literary critics
the psychoanalytic theory of their
choice
into previous literature
that's not actually what's going on with
the lose in part because he's also
trying to undermine
psychoanalysis as a rigid
way of interpretation as well
i think before we look at these
two important polls and then the other
one that to lose brings up the profit
we have to go backwards a little bit and
look at what he
calls identification and talks about
as having a certain function there which
is actually going to lead him
eventually to saying something about the
american dream
an american dream which is not that of
having you know a car
a house a refrigerator a good job
but a different kind of american dream
which he says the new identification of
the new
world the trait the zone and the
function
before that though we we go back to
this discussion of identification and he
says is there a relation of
identification
between the attorney and bartleby so is
this a
useful way of making sense out of these
characters and what they represent or
what they
mean what they have to teach us and he
says well
okay what is identification when we when
we use that term
this is actually a really great place to
bring up an additional point
there's a lot of terms especially when
it comes to literary theory
or philosophy or their intersection
where we throw them around and people
think they know what they mean but
unless we break them down as duluth is
doing here
into their parts and then put them back
together we often don't know what we're
talking about so
deluse himself says all right what is
identification he says what is this
relation
in what direction does it move now he
says most often
so he's not saying in every case but
most often
an identification seems to bring into
play
three elements which are able to
interchange
or permutate right so
these they're not interchanging
necessarily in the sense that one is is
actually
taking the place of the other in the
sense of
absorbing its function although you know
they can kind of veer
in that direction depending on what work
we're looking at
rather they can change in what they are
and then a change in one typically
is going to presage or produce
a change in the other so what are these
three things well we've got some sort of
representation and he's going to use a
couple different ways of talking about
that
we have a subject we'll talk about what
a subject means in just a moment
and then we have this subject's attempt
to do something with itself
and the representation or image to
harmonize them to integrate them
in some way so
let's talk about each of these in term
the first one
a form an image or a representation
then he says two other things a portrait
a model a paradigm right
so when we identify
we are picking out what it is we want to
identify with
what we are identifying ourself towards
and this could be a person this could
also be the notion
of a function like you know sart's
example of the waiter who's trying too
hard to be a waiter
and just a waiter it could be the
soldier who wants to stand at attention
all the time or be a hard ass
or things like that there's some sort of
idea some sort of image there
then he says a subject
or at least a virtual subject and he
doesn't actually tell us that much about
this
but we should unpack that what does it
mean to be a subject it means that you
have the capacity to some degree to
self-determine you have agency
you are driven by thoughts
feelings emotions drives commitments
the the effect of breaking your
commitments all those things belong to
a subject you're a subject i'm a subject
you know are fictional characters
like sherlock holmes are subjects as
well that could be a virtual subject or
in this case bartleby or the attorney
right and then we have
uh he says the subject's attempt efforts
to assume a form to appropriate the
image
so that that sounds like it's it's um
absorbing the image right
but appropriating the image the next
thing that he says
gives us a better idea to adapt itself
to this image
and this image to itself so you know
i'll give you an example you know when i
was a young man
and getting into lifting weights you
know there's a certain look that you put
on there's certain ways in which
you lift the weights and you try to make
sure that you're like conforming to that
because you want to fit in
and you want people to see you in a
certain way even though you actually
there's a non-coincidence between the
ideal and you right and and we can do
this all sorts of other things
you have a job right you need to be
professional what is what is
professional professional is kind of a
form of representation and then you try
to adapt yourself to that
even though uh you're kind of a screw-up
and not
fitting in with this notion of
professionalism
all that much if you do succeed in it
you'll manage to
uh truncate your yourself as a human
being and maybe turn yourself into
something less than a subject
so he goes on and he talks about this as
being
mimetic right and he says this is a
complex operation that passes through
all the adventures of resemblance and
that always risks
now notice these two clinical terms here
falling into
neurosis right where you're you're
desperately trying to
become that that thing or to
seem to be that thing and it's not quite
getting there the neurotic never
actually is
completely happy with what's going on or
narcissistic you do think that you are
that thing you do think you you are the
center of the universe
and you behave that way and that's why
you're such a jerk to everybody else
around you
you don't you know you're still
maladaptive in that respect
so he talks about this as a memetic
rivalry and he says
it mobilizes a paternal function
in general an image of the father par
excellence
and the subject is the son even if the
determinations are interchangeable and
this is something that
goes on all the time right and it
doesn't necessarily have to be
your dad in the sense of the person who
you know contributed the sperm to the
egg
or your dad in the sense of the person
who raised you could be
somebody else who has that paternal
function as well some sort of authority
somebody who's given the the opportunity
to
tell you how you ought to be and to
punish or reward
and you try to make that happen and it
doesn't necessarily have to be a father
it could also be a mother it could also
be um
you know somebody who's who's not
connected with any sex in particular
we could imagine all sorts of alternate
examples of this but here we're talking
about paternal function
now a little bit later duluz
says that in melville's
works he says many of melville's novels
begin with images or portraits and seem
to tell the story
of an upbringing under a paternal
function
but once what ends up happening is this
gets
this goes off track it gets subverted
and it does so
through melville's own way of depicting
this
and he says we still have a process of
identification
rather than following the adventures of
the neurotic it has now become
psychotic a little bit of schizophrenia
escapes the neurosis of the old world
and then he talks about bringing
together
three distinctive characteristics and
he's doing a little bit of sleight of
hand i would say here
that will walk our way through a little
bit of misdirection
perhaps so the first thing
he says in in place of the former
representation or image
what we get is the formless trait of
expression what does that mean
there isn't an actual form there is a
kind of
nothingness there a thing that has
yet to be worked out we don't know what
we're trying to model ourself
after but we have an expression and
i prefer not to i would prefer not to
is an example of that kind of expression
but we can have other expressions
as as well so
he goes on and he says in the second
place there's no longer
a subject that tries to conform to the
image
and either succeeds or fails
but we still do kind of have a subject
right so that's why i've got subject
here and that subject he says
instead of that we have a zone and he
uses three terms here
in distinction indiscernibility
ambiguity that seems to be established
between
two terms as if they'd reach the point
immediately preceding their respective
differentiation
not a similitude but a slippage an
extreme
proximity and an absolute contiguity
an unnatural alliance
well two terms what two terms there is
still a subject there
even though deluse is saying now there's
there's you know we're replacing the
subject
you still have a subject as one of those
terms but now you have this zone
and this is a zone as he says not of
mimesis
imitation uh trying to you know make
one's way to the image and make the
image oneself
but rather of becoming and he uses as a
prime example here
ahab's identification with the whale in
striking moby dick the whale
he strikes himself moby dick is the wall
shove near with which he merges so
that's you know an
antagonistic relation red burn renounces
the image of the father
in favor of the ambiguous traits of the
mysterious
brother peer does not imitate his father
but reaches the zone of proximity
where he can no longer be distinguished
from his half-sister isabelle and
becomes himself
woman so there's a lot of different
modes of possible
becoming here and then he goes down a
little bit and then he says
in the third place so now we're actually
getting
a third thing so what does that mean
well the zone is the subject of the
subject is the zone
even though the subject is part of the
zone in the third place he says
psychosis pursues its dream
of establishing now what uh uh
harmonization an adaptation of image to
subject no
well is it then just modeled after
formless trait of expression we got that
on one side and a zone on the other side
and we're trying to reconcile them no
it's
something different a dream of
universal fraternity he says
that no longer passes through the father
but is built on the ruins
of paternal function a function that
presupposes the dissolution of all
images of the father so
this he says you know all things can
transform into each other the woman
becomes a sister
the other man a brother so this isn't
just a when you know the losers using
this term fraternity over and over
again it doesn't mean boys club you know
no girls allowed or anything like that
it means a breakdown
of this ordering function that he's
calling the paternal function that sets
everything
into its proper place and then would
allow like a you know
orderly succession instead here people
are discovering
who and what they are in relation to
each other
and sometimes the results are very
surprising right
there has to be a certain kind of
freedom to to allow that so
identification becomes something
different in
what's happening here and this is where
he brings up
the american dream with the new
identification
trait zone and function right and he
talks about melvilian psychiatry so this
is where we want to talk about the
he talks about two types at first
monomaniacs
ahab a prime example of that
and in in billy budd clagartz would be
another
example and then hypochondriacs billy
bought himself
bartleby the scrivener some other
characters
as well so he says melvilian psychiatry
invokes two poles monomaniacs
hypochondriacs demons
and angels torturers and victims the
swift and the slow the thundering and
the petrified
the unpunishable because beyond all
punishment
and the irresponsible beyond all iris
beyond all responsibilities so we've got
these
two very interesting types here
and he goes on and he says you know ahab
klagar they're both breaking a pact
a law an agreement ahab is supposed to
pursue whatever whale
comes in his way instead he's like we're
going after that white whale
you know forget all the other ones right
uh
clagart is supposed to he's the master
at arms
he's supposed to administer um
you know discipline equally and he
focuses in
on billy budd and he does so out of envy
but also
kind of you know perhaps love as well
he's not supposed to do that
and these are the people the monomaniacs
who
you know monomania is you've got an
object that you're
driving after and everything else takes
a back seat to it
no matter who gets hurt no matter what
gets broken
on the way and duluz calls these kinds
of people
those involved with metaphysical
perversion
so it's not just an ethical perversion
or an aesthetic perversion it's a
metaphysical perversion the world
that they're working in is the worse off
for them in many respects
he also a little bit later
calls them masters of
reason and this is a very interesting
idea here he talks about this this new
logic right
and he tells us that there is no such
thing as reason it exists only in bits
and pieces
and so the monomaniacs are masters of
reason
which is why they're so difficult to
surprise but this is because theirs is a
delirium of action because they make use
of reason
make it serve their sovereign ends which
in truth are highly unreasonable
so there's an irrationality and their
use of reason
is not just instrumental in the way that
a bureaucrat might be but
they will use reason however they're
they're the ultimate bullshitters really
they'll make arguments but they don't
believe in any of the arguments they're
just trying to get their
thing the hypochondriacs the angelic
types he describes in a different way he
says that
these these people are creatures of
innocence and purity
stricken with a constitutive weakness
but also with a strange
beauty they prefer a
nothingness of the will rather than a
will to nothingness the
monomaniacs have a will to nothingness
the hypochondriacs have a
nothingness of the will they can only
survive
by becoming stoned by denying the will
and sanctifying themselves in the
suspension
such are sir cyrano billy budd and above
all
bartleby which is why he's bringing that
up here
they're always being betrayed you know
he calls them angels or saintly
hypochondriacs
and he also in talking about reason says
that they
are the outcasts of reason
so that's an interesting way to
describe what's going on they don't they
don't make use of
the pretext the reasonings the arguments
that they they could
and he says um with it they are outcasts
of reason without our being able to know
if they have excluded themselves
in order to obtain something reason
cannot give them the indiscernible the
unnamable with
with which they will be able to merge
and then we have a third group
that he calls the prophets
so there exists a third type of
character in melville the one
on the side of the law the guardian
of the divine and human laws so
you know um ishmael and moby dick
captain vera and billy budd the attorney
in bartleby
all have this power he says to see
they're capable of
grasping and understanding the beings of
primary nature the great
monomonaicle demons are the saintly
innocents
but they themselves have some ambiguity
as well behind their paternal mask
they have a kind of double
identification with the innocent towards
whom they feel a genuine love
also with the demon because they break
their pact with the innocent
they love each in their own manner and
they they betray
so they're unable even though they're
they've got the law on their
side and they're on the side of the law
to hold back the monomaniacs because
they don't care about the law they're
going to do whatever the hell they're
going to do
regardless of it and the law ends up
you know being we could say
taking in into its web the
hypochondriacs and they can't make
adequate space for it i mean the captain
in in billy budd is definitely like
enforcing the law
the attorney in bartleby the scrivener
is actually trying to make a lot of room
to try you know he's like let's think
this through
can't we make this work and so there's a
more nice approach you could say which
is still though the paternal function
it's still a kind of charity or
philanthropy
which then falls flat in the face of
that particular
hypochondriac who's going to get you
know arrested
and and die in in jail
interestingly um the lose calls these
prophets witnesses narrators
interpreters they're the ones who
themselves
don't tie in with what he's going to
call primary nature which we'll talk
about
elsewhere they are part of secondary
nature but they um they they attest to
it they are
within the stories giving us
what's going on they're the ones
communicating with us
now there's a problematic you know when
we talk about psychiatry
what is the point of psychiatry is it
just to like come up with cool
classifications
oh i'm a paranoid oh i'm a schizophrenic
oh
i'm a this i'm a this i'm a this no
ultimately there's supposed to be some
sort of
things getting better or at least things
not getting worse
and deluse identifies what he thinks
melville is up to this problematic he
talks about
as liberating humanity
from this paternal function he says
what is the biggest problem haunting
melville's body of work
so he frames it and again we'll talk
about this elsewhere in
uh he frames it in terms of the original
and secondary nature the
inhuman with the with the human but he
also talks about
um the paternal function he says that
what captain vira and the attorney
demonstrate is there are no good fathers
there are only monstrous devouring
fathers and petrified fatherless sons
if humanity can be saved it will only be
through the
dissolution or deca decomposition of the
paternal
function and then he talks about this
moment where ahab
invoking saint elmo's fire discovers
that the father is himself a lost son
and orphan
whereas the son is the son of nothing of
everyone a
brother and he says as joyce will say
paternity does not exist that is an
emptiness of nothingness
so you know if we can break free of the
fascination that
paternity and the paternal function
exercises
on us then we can move on to something
better a kind of
fraternity or you know we might just
call this
humanity because again deluse although
he's using very gendered language
is it's clear here that it's not
just brothers uh he says man
is indeed the blood brother of his
fellow man and and woman
his blood sister and then he
will conclude this by something really
interesting that melville is saying
or rather deluse is saying according to
melville this is the community of
celibates drawing its members into an
unlimited
becoming a brother a sister
all the more true for no longer being
his
or hers since all property all
proprietorship has disappeared
a burning passion deeper than love
since it no longer has either substance
or qualities but traces the zone of
indiscernibility
in which it passes through all
intensities in every direction
extending it all the way to homosexual
relation between brothers
and passing through the incestuous
relation between brother
and sister this is a way to lose figures
it and he asked how can this community
be realized i mean there's a tension
there right if you're going to talk
about
um homosexuality or incest you're
thinking about things in sexual terms
but he's also talking about this as the
community of celibates those who are
you might say renouncing their sexuality
in order to open up a greater scope of
freedom
i don't think that this is completely
resolved
in here but at least it gives you an
idea about what's supposed to be
happening duluz clearly thinks that
this other kind of identification is
preferable to you know the psychotic
identification
preferable to the neurotic or
you know whatever else we're going to
we're going to call it uh kind of
identification the square
identification you might say and you
know
the the goal is to get past these three
types
in a certain way or create a space in
which
the hypochondriacs could continue to
exist and maybe the profits could be
reconciled
we don't really know what we're supposed
to do with the monomaniacs though
there's never a resolution of that
here in this work we just know that they
are the proverbial bull in the china
shop
wherever they happen to go so that is
you know what's going on here in terms
of
the loses appropriation of clinical
language and concepts in his
his notion of melvilia and psychiatry
you